i'm going to split into it very
glamorous a little spit
that could make a big difference from
next month
staff and students at exeter university
will be getting this saliva test
regularly
and it's makers say that's just the
start it's turning testing into an
industry
rather than a cottage industry it's
using the best of british know-how
to deliver this at serious volume
to the public but you can't switch it on
overnight this is going to require
decisions now so that we're going to be
ready to be able to do that
the government's got a really ambitious
plan for mass testing
which leaked documents suggest could
involve up to 10
million tests a day now my sources say
the real number is closer to between two
and four million
but even so that's a hell of a lot and
to do that
they'll need tests like this which are
currently being processed
right up there in the lab
the tests are processed within 24 hours
quick
but far slower than the 20-minute home
test promised by the government
mps pointed out that only technology
that doesn't exist yet i'm going to
depart from my script here because i've
heard the naysayers before and i've
heard the people on the other side
complain we'll never get testing going
and they're the same old voices if the
technology comes off
it will be possible even for challenging
sectors like theaters
to get closer to normal before christmas
that's a big claim which scientists fear
may offer
false hope to struggling businesses
they're talking about these new tests
being less accurate than our current
test
and that's expected because it's going
to be a portable
and fast technology it's a compromise
which is being made
so it might be that they're only
detecting 50 or 60 or 70 people of
the people who have covid the difficulty
of containing the virus was laid bare by
the latest statistics
today's test and trace figures show nine
thousand
9
864 people tested positive in england
that's a 43 increase the highest
since test and trace was launched in may
but contact traces in england
were only reaching 69.2 percent of
contacts
or if you like missing three in every
10.
that might not be helped by the absence
of a contact tracing app in england
scotland's launch today although that
couldn't disguise
underlying bad news our latest estimate
of the r number
is that it is now above one possibly as
high as 1.5
so rather than the threat to public
health receding the pandemic is at this
stage
accelerating again across europe
cases are rising mainland portugal the
latest entry on england's quarantine
list
is testing the answer if it is
it may need to arrive soon roland
manthal
sky news